acting homeland security secretary chad
wolf has resigned as the country
is on high alert ahead of the
inauguration his announcement did not
mention wednesday's riot but wolfe is
the third cabinet member to resign
following wednesday's siege we're joined
now by cbs news senior national security
analyst fran townsend she served
as homeland security adviser to
president george w bush frank good
morning to you
let's start with chad wolfe at least on
paper he is the gentleman in charge of
security for the inauguration
and his explanation for resigning is
short on details
what do you think is going on here
look i i think the the resignation
of the homeland security secretary nine
days before a national security special
event that he is
himself is responsible for is both
disgraceful and irresponsible
the u.s secret service is the agency
who's in charge of the security for the
inauguration
but they work for the secretary of
homeland security look
he didn't other cabinet secretaries said
they left because
of what happened last week at the
capitol chad wolfe cites a
litigation here in new york that's been
going on for some time
i think that's a it's a cover for
somebody who's a coward
i think he just doesn't want to be
responsible for inauguration security
after the debacle last week
it doesn't seem like a setup for success
i want to talk about the two capital
hill police officers who were suspended
for roles in the riot there are 10 other
investigations we are told
as you prepare security for inauguration
how do you
acknowledge and deal with the fact that
there could be among the many heroic and
courageous members of that security team
some people who are sympathetic to
the pro-trump mob that assaulted the
capitol
tony it's very disturbing but we have to
give the capitol hill police
this much credit right they're looking
to root out those people
and they're not the only ones you're
going to rely on for security at the
inauguration you've got the u.s secret
service you're going to have 10 000
national guard troops
and you have an ongoing fbi
investigation with
lots of information and lots of leads
and so i think that the capitol hill
police are trying to do the best they
can under very difficult circumstances
and i give them credit
for policing their own joe biden says he
wants to appear outside deliver his
speech at the inauguration outside says
he's not
afraid as a security expert are you
concerned for him
well i am i'm always concerned at every
inauguration especially when
the new president walks down
pennsylvania avenue um
but i think that this will be the most
secure
and you'll have a greater security
presence than ever before they've
already closed two of
the national monuments i suspect they
will restrict access to the national
mall
uh on inauguration day and so i think
their people are now trying and very
focused to be sure this is the safest
most secure inauguration we've ever seen
i can't stop thinking about nancy
pelosi's observation on 60 minutes that
there was an element of that group that
sieged the capital that were very
coordinated it seemed well planned
if that's true could that group shift
and hit a soft
target at another state capitol whether
it's not this monster security apparatus
set up
absolutely tony and that's why when you
think about the fbi's investigation
there's a treasure trove of evidence in
addition to the videos we've all seen
remember there were two locations they
are near the rnc and dnc that had pipe
bombs
you know unexploded explosives
are a treasure trove of information
there's fingerprints there's
dna there's signatures in terms of how
these are put together
the component pieces and so if this is
an organized
if this was a really organized mob that
was giving direction
the fbi has got a lot of information
that they can follow to try and
understand that and prevent it again
from it happening again
all right fran townsend who will not be
writing a letter of recommendation for
chad wolfe's next position it sounds
like
grant thank you very much